you live in the property you should fix
it or take better care of it depends on
what it is I've literally had people
call me up and say my lights aren't
working it's an emergency and then I've
been oh man they're not working I'm so
sorry bang send someone out paid an
emergency electrician and the light
bulbs just need change it I personally
do agree that you should change your own
light bulb but also what then happens
like so some people have made repairs or
like fixed up their property or like
whatever you know changed their property
in some way you know and change the
light bulbs but their landlords are like
you shouldn't have done that cuz like
we're supposed to be they're just idiot
idiot landlords I've had a landlord like
that they were like oh you have to call
us every time like when you need the
light bulb change I can buy my own light
bulb I want I want to put a picture up
on the wall you're not allowed I'm not
about that life my tenants are my
customers they give me money they should
be grateful to me I should be grateful
to them win-win